es un placer estar acá esta mañana con
ustedes y poderles compartir un poco
sobre mi pasión y platicarles de mi
trabajo y el poder que ha tenido en mi
vida
el movimiento creativo
soy fernando moreno nací en este hermoso
ciudad en la paz hace 26 años y recuerdo
que desde que yo era un pequeñito ya me
fascinaba y me entregaba mucho como
surgía de estas máquinas aparentemente
sin vida sonidos
luces colores y cómo podían ayudar a
resolver muchos problemas o facilitarme
la vida en muchos ámbitos de mi vida
cotidiana
gracias al esfuerzo y el apoyo de mis
padres junto con este deseo de aprender
llegué a la universidad de guadalajara
donde pude estudiar esta carrera
maravillosa de la ingeniería biomédica
puede conocer de una forma profesional
cómo funcionan las máquinas cuáles son
los principios que hacen que esto suceda
esta magia suceda y lo que para mí es la
máquina más perfecta el cuerpo humano
puede aprender cómo funciona este cuerpo
y cómo gracias a la tecnología podemos
crear un puente maravilloso para mejorar
la calidad de vida de millones de
personas entonces
como toda etapa terminó y la maña
recuerdo a la mañana siguiente a mi
graduación estaba acostado viendo el
techo y pensando ahora que siguen
oficialmente soy un ni ni ni estudio ni
trabajo y mis opciones serán dos una
quedarme en guadalajara buscar un
trabajo lo cual era posible o la otra
era dejar todo y regresar a esta hermosa
ciudad
después de un segundo y haber vendido
todas mis cosas yo ya estaba acá de
regreso pero no regresaba el mismo que
se había ido traía en mi baúl muchos
proyectos que yo quería seguir
desarrollando siempre ha sido muy
inquieto entonces me di a la tarea de
buscar en la paz un espacio donde
pudiera seguir desarrollando y
aterrizando estas ideas y me toque me
topé con pared al darme cuenta que estos
espacios si existían pero eran muy pocos
y eran limitados a la comunidad
estudiantil o a los maestros oa los
investigadores entonces
que iba a ser yo de todos modos quería
desarrollar estos proyectos y la única
opción que quedó fue empezarlo por mi
cuenta de reuniones entonces no tenía ni
dinero ni trabajo como hacerle la
primera persona que creyó en mí fue mi
papá y así empezó esto empecé con un
préstamo en 'números rojos' pero con
muchas ganas de lograr esta idea que yo
tenía en mi mente
y pues fue así como en el 2016 se inició
esta aventura inició el taller
científico yo era un ingeniero no tenía
conocimientos de negocios entonces tomé
algunos cursos de emprendimiento otros
tantos de finanzas puse mi proyecto en
el papel y participé en convocatorias de
emprendedores donde no solamente fui
beneficiado con él con el apoyo sino que
fui seleccionado como un caso de éxito
en la semana nacional del emprendedor
entonces con este dinero podría hacer
realidad mi sueño tener este espacio
este taller lleno de herramientas lleno
de tecnología
tecnología eso es que usamos todos los
días pero que muchas veces no sabemos
qué hay detrás no sabemos ni cómo
funciona pero ya está en todas partes de
nuestra vida entonces eso fue una tarea
que yo me di a través del taller
científico a explicarlo y compartir a
las personas cómo es que estas máquinas
cómo es que la electricidad las líneas
de ensamble la automatización los robots
el internet está cambiando las cosas y
cómo nos comunicamos entre nosotros
mismos e interactuamos con él con el
mundo
me tocó vivir
en la revolución del internet la época
de los datos nunca antes en la historia
de la humanidad habíamos estado tan
conectados como hoy en día
y existe un tabú existe el tabú de que
la tecnología es una barrera que nos
separa y yo vengo a compartirles como la
tecnología no es una barrera sino es una
extensión de nuestras limitaciones
físicas entonces por fin ya tenía el
dinero las ganas de hacerlo y tomé la
mejor decisión o una de las mejores
decisiones de mi vida y fue haber
comprado una impresora 3d que es una
tecnología que me apasiona tanto que
permítanme les explico cómo funciona y
las maravillas que podemos hacer todos
los que existieron en los años 90 seguro
recuerdan este juguetito rojo con el
cual podía dibujar utilizando dos
perillas si tu móvil es una se
desplazaba en el eje o en el vertical y
si movía la otra se desplazaba la línea
en el eje x o en el horizontal si tú
movidas las dos podías crear estos
dibujos entonces si yo hago eso mismo
pero en lugar de dibujar con tinta
utilizo plástico derretido y hago este
dibujo y me levanto y vuelvo a hacerlo y
me levanto y vuelvo a hacerlo entonces
estoy creando
un objeto físico tangible con plástico
duro y eso yo lo podía hacer desde la
sala de mi casa
yo puede crear cualquier objeto que se
me pudiera imaginar que pudiera diseñar
en la computadora o incluso descargarlo
de internet y esto fue algo que me
fascinó
y cuando yo me juntaba con mis amigos
les platica oye que fíjate tengo una
impresora 3d y puedo hacer esto y esto
otro y me decía oye yo tengo este
problema o esta idea se puede hacer
pues sí sí se puede y después me iba con
otro amigo y le platicaba lo mismo y se
le ocurría otra idea entonces yo me
quedé pensando bueno las posibilidades
de estos son infinitas entre todo este
universo de objetos que yo puedo hacer
realidad cuál es el que me puede generar
un mayor valor pero en un valor
económico sino un impacto realmente en
la sociedad y fue así como llegué a uno
de los primeros pilares de este
movimiento creativo el compartir
el compartir porque de nada me sirven
todos esos conocimientos en el ático de
mi mente y de nada me sirve todas las
posibilidades que puedo construir con
esta máquina en la sala de mi casa si no
está al servicio del ser humano si no
está ayudando a mejorar el mundo como yo
la encontré entonces decidí involucrarme
en esta aventura que es
ser un voluntario en una organización
internacional sin fines de lucro donde
voluntarios anónimos en todo el mundo
han creado un catálogo de prótesis de
mano y de brazo que están disponibles de
forma gratuita en internet y que yo
puedo descargar ajustarlo a las medidas
de los pacientes imprimirlo y entregar
estas prótesis de forma altruista ya que
es de muy bajo costo entonces
pues dije por qué no vamos a hacerlo me
registre imprime una prótesis de
ensambles y después de mucho tiempo de
trabajo y de colaboración con gente
increíble de todo el mundo llegan los
resultados y una imagen habla mal que
más que mil palabras y ahí podemos ver
cómo gracias a la tecnología gracias a
la creatividad a esta evolución
al menos una persona es más feliz al
menos la vida de una persona es mejor
gracias a esto gracias a estos esfuerzos
a nivel mundial y eso me lleva al
segundo punto aprender después de haber
compartido todo esto con muchas personas
increíbles aprendes por supuesto que
aprendes todas las personas saben algo
que tú no y la única manera de acceder a
esa información es compartiendo con
ellos y eso es lo que hacemos también en
el taller en el taller pensamos
construimos buscamos formas nuevas de
solucionar problemas
y cumplimos ejecutamos creamos y nos
vamos una de las grandes mentes de los
tiempos modernos dijo que la creatividad
es de inteligencia divirtiéndose y no
debemos de subestimar
el poder que tiene canalizar la
creatividad de un niño dándole las
herramientas y los conocimientos
necesarios
yo les quiero presentar esta mañana a
una persona que para mí es muy
importante con la que he compartido
experiencias increíbles y él es franco
canseco al que quiero invitar que pase
al escenario
[Aplausos]
bienvenido francos
y bueno esta mañana les vamos a platicar
cómo fue nuestra experiencia y como un
invento nos llevó del otro lado del
mundo a compartir no sólo con méxico
sino con el mundo entero
como una idea puede cambiar la realidad
de las personas pero que mejor que
escucharlo de sus propias palabras los
dejo con francos
[Aplausos]
me llamo franco y tengo 9 años ustedes
les gusta dormir
bueno dormido es un placer es una
necesidad no lo digo yo lo diga la
organización mundial de la salud porque
cuando duermes crees eso de buen humor
no te plasmas tanto que 'no es muy feliz
entonces si una es imaginaria traspasa
ya sino durmieras muchas cosas más la
verdad en secretaria de salud dice que
méxico el 18.8 de la población padece de
insomnio y yo soy uno de ellos por lo
que se me ocurre meter el remedio en la
banda neutrónica en como se me ocurrió
yo tengo problemas para dormir así que
si no corre mete algo para no dormir
pero después de investigar mucho y leer
me di cuenta que dormir era muy
importante y no podía inventar algo para
no dormir tenía que inventar algo para
poder dormir
en
entonces después de ir a clases de
neurociencias conversación fernández
moreno que me ha ayudado mucho me di
cuenta que mandaban de pulsos de adentro
para afuera
podrías está volar un dron entonces dije
yo voy a mandar en pos de dentro para
fuera por al mando de impulsos de afuera
para adentro y así se me ocurre mentar
la banda en el tónica
la banda en el tónica es un dispositivo
capaz de ayudarlo a poder dormir y
relajarse sin tomar medicamentos y tiene
cuatro elementos un transmisor de una
ciudad artificial eso posiciones
electromagnéticas hecho en el hearts que
se coloca en el lóbulo occipital que es
aquí
con unas piedras llamadas turbo líneas
que producen ondas alfa y se colocan
aquí
unos audífonos de una música relajante
llamada wireless que por sentir que ha
probado que sea música de memoria el 65%
el estrés y como último recurso tiene
una máscara toda la oscuridad porque la
total oscuridad desnudez
el 30 por ciento estrés y aumenta la
producción de melatonina y que la
melatonina una hormona que te va a
producir a producir el chico del sueño
para que la banda funcione tengo que
poner la banda por 8 minutos y sus
cuatro elementos te mandarán al punto de
relajación en el que tienes que estar
antes de quedarte dormido
y su investigación para saber si que un
invento funcionaba investigaciones en
entrevistas los sentidos y doctores en
pruebas como el extremo programas y
hacer y al final me di cuenta de algo
también método se emocionaba
por lo
por lo que ya está en proceso de patente
por lo que está en proceso de patente y
allí están sus papeles los papeles
lo que les quiero decir es que si tienen
una idea un sueño o una meta trabajen
esfuércense y hagan lo posible por
hacerlo realidad porque también tiene
sus recompensas tuve la gran oportunidad
de participar en las explosiones las
internacional 2018 chile a donde pueda
presentar mi invento y conocer a
personas de varios países como colombia
brasil y chile
argentina y muchos más pero lo más
increíble porque puede conocer a
científicos de la nasa a los que les
interesó mucho mi proyecto y ya pero y
yo aprendí en muchos de ellos
es un proceso de largo
en el 2016
con un simple dibujo llorando de 18
tengo el prototipo funcional
gracias
[Aplausos]
pues muchas gracias yo soy franco que
todos estamos muy orgullosos de lo que
has logrado a tus 9 años
yo les pido que observen esta imagen
dos años de proceso dos años donde todo
esto se transformó desde una idea loca
que pueda tener un niño un dibujo que se
le ocurrió hacer y como con esfuerzo con
el apoyo de su familia investigando y no
dejando su sueño abajo dos años después
esto se convierte en un prototipo
terminado con una patente en proceso
participando a nivel latinoamérica y no
sólo participando sino siendo reconocido
méxico como la mejor delegación
latinoamericana
y ese es el poder del movimiento
creativo el último pilar es amar amar lo
que haces amar tu creatividad amar tus
ideas amar a tus maestros amar a tus
compañeros a tus papás
yo quiero hacerles una invitación esta
mañana para que todos busquen ese
espacio donde brillan esa zona donde se
sienten que incluso no necesitan que les
paguen para hacer ese trabajo y estoy
convencido de que el mundo necesita más
personas que amen lo que hacen para
mejorar
por último y abordando de una forma
científica me gustaría compartirles que
solamente somos visitantes en tiempo y
en espacio nuestro paso por esta vida es
temporal y antes de regresar a la
esencia estamos aquí para compartir
para aprender
y para amar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]